(upbeat electronic music)
- Look, my nail polish
matches the elevator.
(upbeat electronic music)
They've got valet, we're in Los Angeles,
you got a valet for your brunch.
Hello, everyone, today is a great day.
We are going to brunch.
Every time I try to vlog you--
- This was B roll.
- Ugh, the B roll.
- It is such a nice day.
After it rains, it's so
clean and crisp here.
- Well, it hasn't rained in a while.
- The week after it rains.
- [Jenna] Oh yeah, it's nice.
- [Justine] Oh, excellent.
- Perfect time to hike,
'cause it's not dusty.
(upbeat electronic music)
- [Justine] Well that's beautiful.
- [Jenna] That's nice.
- [Justine] Wow, thank you so much.
- How am I eating this, it's huge!
- That's what you said.
(upbeat electronic music)
That was a super quick brunch.
Now it's time for me to go home,
change, get ready, and then
we're gonna go for a hike.
(upbeat electronic music)
Seatbelt, safety first, guys.
Now we're off to my house,
because I've got to get ready,
and change, and prepare myself for this
incredible hike that we're about to do.
I'm so out of shape.
(upbeat electronic music)
Guys, if you haven't heard
the new Martin Garrix song,
mm, definitely recommend it.
♪ It was great at the very start ♪
♪ Hands on each other ♪
(upbeat electronic music)
Almost time for our hike.
Um, I might have fallen
asleep, so I took a little nap.
Jenna's a little bit upset
with both Matt and me.
We're both not very good at doing things,
and Jenna is very on time,
and always quite prompt.
What about Matt and I, you say?
(laughs) Yeah, we're not quite as prompt.
(upbeat electronic music)
Oh yeah, there's a lot
of people here today.
- [Matt] Gotta get some
rocks outta my shoes.
- [Justine] You wearing your
Yeezy ka-meezy soo-at-boos
today?
- No, no Yeezy Ka-meezy soo-boo-boos.
- Yeezy Ka-meezy?
You know, you guys are
gonna see Kanye come out
with the next line of
his whatever the heck
they're called, they're gonna be called
yeezy ka-meezy sa-meezy's.
And know that I came up with it.
- [Matt] You know what, Justine,
you say a lot of dumb things,
but I think you kinda just
took the cake with that one.
(Matt and Justine laugh)
- Oh god.
- Usually I let you rock, but
today it's just not the day.
- Okay, I think if you compared the dumb
things that I've said to the dumb
things that Kanye has
said, I think he wins.
- Kanye?
Have you ever...
Oh my god.
Just came out, this was Dratini nest,
so Jenna and I came here
to just farm Dratini,
we were here for like
three, or four hours,
the sun was going down,
and we decided, alright
that's gonna be it for today.
I was like 10 Dratini's away from--
(Jenna laughs)
- I'm trolling Matt.
Silly he looks, even though
I'm doing the same thing.
- [Jenna] Listen, I know--
- But he's even worse.
- He's so loud.
- Because he's so loud.
- When we were at the zoo,
he was outside--
- Oh my god.
- He was outside the girls' restroom,
and I was inside peeing,
and it echoed, tunneled inside,
and it sounded like he was--
- [Justine] Look at him,
look at him, look at him.
- It sounded like he
was vlogging in my ear,
let's go pee.
- Are you with that guy?
- [Justine] We are.
- He's pretty loud.
(Justine laughs)
- [Jenna] He's so loud.
- [Guy In White Shirt] Yeah,
good luck. (Justine laughs)
- [Matt] They changed the nest--
- Oh my god, oh my god,
that was the best thing
I've ever got on film.
- [Jenna] Yeah, good luck.
(Justine laughs)
(playful piano music)
- [Justine] Get the B roll!
- [Matt] Back up, just like three feet.
- We don't have time, the sun is setting!
- [Matt] Okay, let's go.
- If you didn't take 17 hours to edit,
you could have done this all you wanted.
Well I think I'm gonna
hang out with myself.
- Shut up. (laughs)
(playful music)
- [Jenna] I found bigfoot
here once, Sasquatch.
- That just popped up in my feed,
we hunted Sasquatch here.
- Matt has never hunted
Bigfoot with us before.
- Yes, he has.
- Has he?
- Big Bear.
Or like Arrow Head, or somewhere we went.
- [Jenna] Um, that
wasn't an official hunt.
- It was a small hunt, true,
we didn't have any gear,
we didn't have anything.
But our last official one I think was here
with Jenna Marbles.
- [Jenna] Yeah.
- Uh, my name is Jenna.
And I'm here on Squatch Watch.
I'm an Optics Engineer.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Guys, I'm really struggling.
(sighs)
(upbeat electronic music)
I can actually hear water here.
Usually you can't hear anything.
Or see anything, it's dry.
(upbeat electronic music)
♪ There's no use in looking back ♪
♪ Gotta laugh ♪
♪ I gotta live ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm so over the past ♪
♪ And I'm living it fast ♪
♪ Mm ♪
♪ I like nature's cold blinds ♪
♪ Ready for a crazy night ♪
♪ I can hear your heart beat ♪
It's time for dinner now.
Oh!
- [Jenna] Sorry!
- [Justine] Whoa.
- [Jenna] Whoa!
- You think I was talking to who?
- [Jenna] Like people, us.
- Mm, yeah.
Hi!
Hi, baby, oh.
Come on, give mommy kisses.
(upbeat electrical music)
What are you doing, what is happening?
What are you doing?
You need a bath, baby.
You need to go to the groomers.
So this is a great
restaurant, I love it here.
Everyone's so nice and friendly.
Every time I come here,
I get a salad, and a meatball,
like a meatball is my main course,
a salad's like my starter.
- I got eggplant parm.
- [Justine] Do you think that's weird?
- I've got vodka.
- (laughs) Matt's happy.
We do have some wine, it's very good.
- They look the same,
so like sometimes I think this is water.
- You know what I did,
I only had one piece of
bread instead of like three.
- Matt's being, he's fit.
I had a lot.
- That hike was pretty intense,
we burned a lot of calories.
- Meatball?
- [Matt] It's ground beef.
- Yeah, a ball of meat.
Literally exactly what it says.
- Well I didn't know what kind.
- I've just always been weirded out
by the idea of meatballs.
Like chicken parm, ooh.
- Chicken parm with no cheese.
- Yeah, but just chicken
and spaghetti is the best.
- It's good, I agree.
Yeah, this is life.
What ya looking for?
Oh wow, that's a very hefty--
- [Jenna] Are those peanuts, butter?
- No.
- [Jenna] Oh my god, not peanut butter?
- [Justine] You're fit.
- They're just Christmas M&M's.
- [Justine] Yeah, they were on sale.
- It's like February.
Jenna and Justine have
never seen Interstellar.
And that's what we're about to watch.
- [Justine] We are.
- And I've made a demand that they
cannot go on their phones,
they actually have to watch
the movie, because I know
how Jenna watches movies.
- [Justine] What do
you think of this, Jen?
Maddie, this is alcohol.
- [Jenna] Oh honey bear, Maddie,
where's your plane?
- [Justine] Look at this.
Can you believe what this is?
It's a cake pop maker,
what do you think, Maddie?
They have cupcake maker, donut maker, wow.
I'm getting all of them.
Alright, so should we start
watching the movie now?
- [Jenna] Yes.
- I need to set the theme, how about this?
Tropical twilight, does that look good?
Look at this.
Oh my gosh, it's so cool,
look at it, the little poppy corns.
Here you go.
- [Matt] Thank you.
- [Justine] Movie night!
- [Matt] Very nice of you.
- Oh, hi, Maddie.
Hi, sweetie, what are you eating?
- [Matt] I feel like you guys
had to have seen this movie.
- [Jenna] The person next to
me sure is talking too loudly.
(Justine laughs)
- Come on, it's funny.
- [Justine] Matt hates
the sound of chewing.
- I do.
- It's next morning, oh my goodness,
that was such a great movie,
watched Interstellar last night,
and watching a movie with Matt
is actually terrible,
he kept yelling at us,
if we would even look at our phone.
You're so cute.
Anyway, I'm gonna edit this vlog,
hope you guys enjoyed it, and
I will see you when I see you.
Probably tomorrow, bye.
Silicone case from Apple.
Nothin' too special.
But the case that you guys
probably saw on my phone
and got a little bit
confused is this case.
It's inside here, it's called peeled case.
This is not sponsored, I'm not gonna say
this case is the reason that
I shattered my phone two times
in 24 hours, I'm reckless, yes.
I was holding my dog, and I had my phone--